Speaker 1: This is absolutely humiliating
video of former Fox News host Bill O'Reilly.
This is, you know, I've said before that there
is really no trend where I've met left wing
media people and right wing media people,
and there's no hard and fast rule about, Oh,
the lefties are nice and the righties aren't.
In fact, my experience has been the exact
opposite.
Some of the most vile, mean rude people I've
met in this business are prominent left wing
hosts.
I'm not going to name them.
I think the one I've named is Ed Schultz.
He, you know, he has passed away.
And at this point, it's sort of irrelevant,
but not a nice guy.
One of the worst people that I've ever met.
Everybody else is still alive.
Most of the right wingers have been super
nice.
I mean, I don't like his politics.
But Mike Huckabee.
Sean Hannity.
I got these.
They're nice people.
When you meet them in person at conferences,
they'll stand around and chat and talk shop
and all of this different stuff.
OK, but there is nice and rude people on both
sides.
Bill O'Reilly has a reputation for being absolutely
vile and disgusting.
I've never met the guy.
We now have a viral video of Bill O'Reilly
at a JetBlue terminal at JFK Airport.
Bill O'Reilly was trying to get to Turks and
Caicos for his vacation, and the flight was
late.
The flight was late.
And Bill O'Reilly absolutely loses it and
starts threatening a JetBlue Gate agent who
has no say whatsoever about when flights come
and go with his job starts threatening.
You're going to lose your job.
Here is Bill O'Reilly.
People who were watching might notice Bill
O'Reilly is looking extremely gaunt.
I knew he was tall.
He looks so skinny that it almost looks unhealthy.
That's an aside.
And here he is, threatening the JetBlue worker
with his job all captured on camera.
And by the way, can I just say.
This was when the mask requirement was still
in place at airports.
Why does he have to pull the mask down to
talk?
I just I don't understand when people do this,
but OK, that's not for me to understand.
So now he's you got into contact.
Speaker 4: Bill O'Reilly on the outside.
Speaker 1: I want to see a manager, you know?
So, yeah, here, Bill.
Bill O'Reilly's asking for the manager.
You're going to do three hours.
Speaker 4: Wait.
Speaker 1: What are you going to do?
It's three hours late, the gate agent doesn't
control that, you're going to find out, you're
going to find out.
Then he does the thing where he looks really
closely at the guy's nametag.
Unidentified: You looking at?
The more than, yeah, year
Speaker 1: now, Bill O'Reilly, who is much
taller than the employee, starts leaning in
intimidating.
This is the most humiliating behavior brand
new violence.
You're threatening with violence, the employee
now says.
Unidentified: You were the one where here.
You.
You're going to lose your
Speaker 1: job and you're going to lose your
job.
We'll see you.
We'll see.
And off goes Bill O'Reilly lumbering away.
You know, one of the things I am nowhere near
as well known as as Bill O'Reilly.
But the number of people that come up to me
in public and say hello has made me realize
I always need to be on my best behavior.
I can't be on a phone yelling at anybody if
I'm at the airport.
I'm going to be extremely polite if I'm talking
to my girlfriend or whatever, I'm going to
make sure that everything always looks as
if everything is going swimmingly and beautifully,
no matter what is going on up, because this
is exactly what I want to avoid.
And the the the yelling at employees and threatening
their job is particularly when don't we all
know how aviation works at this point in time?
I once had a situation where I had a flight
delayed seven hours out of a very small airport
where there was there was.
That's the one flight, and it was delayed
because of weather.
I was miserable.
But what?
I'm going to do this.
The person at the airport doesn't handle the
flight coming and going, and it's just an
absolutely humiliating situation to be caught
in.
And it is not a surprise.
Sometimes rumors are true.
Sometimes rumors are not true.
Bill O'Reilly, widely known as a prick for
lack of a better term.
And coming off exactly that way, and one of
the things that for me is particularly bothersome
is when individuals that are that are wealthier
and in privileged positions are really talking
down to service workers.
I see it more often in restaurants, where
sometimes they will be with people who are
not particularly mean people.
And they just don't treat service workers
well.
They don't treat the waitstaff well, and it
makes me genuinely uncomfortable.
I go out of my way to try to treat people
well.
And Bill O'Reilly clearly doing the opposite
here.
Not a surprise coincides perfectly with what
we thought we knew about Bill O'Reilly.
We'll have the clip on our Instagram at David
Pakman show if you've just been listening
today.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.